what advice would you give to startup
founders about this particular stage
about surviving it
to the five and through the five
employee stage where you yeah well if
your pre-product market fit
the best advice that i have from that
period is
um action produces information so just
just like keep doing stuff you know i
remember like um
yeah paul graham had this great line
like that i think that's his line and he
he was like startups are like sharks if
they stop swimming swimming they die you
know so even if you're like not sure
what to do like just do anything because
when you do it like it'll produce some
information like people liked it they
didn't this was very true for me there
was times where
i just did something um instead of
debating it endlessly and like just try
it you know like all right so we shipped
it and like there was a couple times
where like the minute i shipped it
and i was like i knew i know we built
this wrong but now i have an idea of
what to do next and it wasn't i only
would have had the idea if we had
actually gone through the exercise of
going to build it it's like
my other favorite analogy for this is
that
you're like at the base of a mountain
that's shrouded in fog
and you're looking up at the mountain
and you're trying to think like okay how
do i get up there but you can only see
like three or four steps ahead because
the fog is so thick so you have to just
take steps into the unknown
and when you take three steps another
three steps will be revealed ahead of
you and sometimes you'll end up on some
local maximum you'll have to retrace
your steps or whatever but or come up to
a cliff you know but um
most people in life don't take the steps
into the fog into the unknown because
it's scary or they're like i don't know
what if i fail or like i don't know how
that's gonna work or i might run out of
money or i won't be able to get a job
after or
i don't know whatever reason but that
that is like one of the things that
separates i think entrepreneurial people
with that kind of inclination is that
they have sort of a comfort with this
risk tolerance but it's actually not
really risky if you think about it it's
not like
you know in at least in most um places
like you know if you go to if you go to
a startup and it fails like you're gonna
you're even more valuable to your next
employer right or you can go raise a
seed round pay yourself a salary
try it for like two years or three years
if it doesn't work go get another job
it's not like you're you weren't paying
yourself a salary during that time so i
think i think people overestimate the
risk of doing a startup and they just
never they never start because
it seems crazy and all your friends
think it's silly like that's sort of the
default nature of every big startup idea
it's just basic fear it's the same kind
of fear that if you see a if you're
a guy see a cute girl at a bar it's the
fear associated with coming up to her
yeah you like her asking her it's like
what's the actual risk exactly right um
she'll say i'm no thanks i'm not no
thanks and i guess the risk is like
that's going to be mentally difficult
to deal with rejection so just like it's
mentally difficult to deal with failure
if you if you had a bunch of ideas and
you're excited about them and you
implement them and you realize
they're not good
that could be difficult to keep pushing
through that but i suppose that's life
you're supposed to
you know perseverance through the
failures yeah and then the risk is low
so that's and then the whole time
through the fog up the mountain you're
looking for product market fit yeah
that's right so you know you have it
when the usage of your product keeps
growing without any marketing dollars or
anything like that it's just like more
people keep coming back every week or
month so you're kind of keep you're
basically watching your stats
nothing is working you see these little
wiggles of false hope in your metrics
and you basically just keep talking to
customers fixing the improving the
product talk to customers improve the
product talk to customers
you know and try to run out of money so
be really scrappy
and then if you're lucky you hit some
kind of threshold where like okay the
thing is good enough now or we hit on
some use case and then it'll
organically start to grow a bit
and then then you have a whole different
set of problems once you hit product
market fit which is
how do we scale this thing how do we
hire people
how do we
you know
hire an executive team or raise more
money and like so the problems totally
change
you